now
as a best-selling lgbt women's studies
children's author
i've been thinking more about the
infamous will smith incident at the
oscars it's been interesting really
especially to view this story through
the marginalized lens of an lgbt women's
studies expert my community is so often
ignored in these conversations no matter
how many best-selling books we write
so over the past day or so so um a
consensus has emerged on the left at
least among the race hustlers and other
members of its wokest factions the
settled narrative is that will smith
as a black man
ostensibly in defense of a black woman's
feelings
is entitled to lash out as violently as
he wants in whatever context he wants
that seems to be the sentiment now i
think a few viral tweets might summarize
things for us this one with 134 thousand
likes says chris rock's one joke was
rooted in misogynoir texturism and
ableism degrading a black woman in a
room full of her peers on live tv the
fact that y'all don't see that as
violent is beyond me
yes who has not flown into a violent
rage because of texturism
everyone in my life knows that texturism
much less texturism mixed with massaging
noir is my biggest pet peeve when i hear
texturism
you know they can hear me shouting from
the other room is that texturism are you
guys doing texturism in there
especially as a women's studies
expert they know don't bring don't bring
that mess around me
so i can understand that but still um
also someone in media named um shea
bully concurred posting
black emotions scare white people that's
quite clear y'all shook because you're
used to seeing your favorite black
people wear their masks
then a woman named grace randolph adds
will smith wins best actor he is still
clearly very shaken by what was said
about jada his choice to stand up for
her and the abuse that goes on today of
public figures people of color and more
he will surely speak on this more all
week as will others
the new york assembly woman um by the
name of um i don't know her name but she
joined other politicians like ayanna
presley and jamal bowman in claiming
that chris rock's joke was a form of
violence she tweeted
it is violence to mock someone's health
condition and vulnerability it is
violence to physically assault someone
it is violent to not take responsibility
for violent actions it is violence to
allow and excuse violence it is violence
to call for violence
yes it's violence to excuse violence she
says as she excuses violence
meanwhile the media has gotten in on the
action usa today published an article
with the headline
jada pinkett smith chris rock and why
his hair joke was so problematic
and then forbes asked asks this question
in their headline why are jokes always
at the expense of black women
now
i can answer that um
jokes are not always at the expense of
black women in fact jokes are
almost never at the expense of black
women we might reasonably say that black
women are the least mocked and least
joked about group in the country perhaps
even beating out trans people for that
title
on the rare occasion
that anyone does tell a joke about black
women or about a black woman
individually it is always another black
person telling a joke
i can't remember the last time i've
heard a non-black person tell a joke
about a black woman
much less black women in general
on the other hand
non-white people tell jokes about white
people and especially white women all
the time
the term karen is itself a derogatory
joke about white women which was first
popularized by non-white people
so karen is a joke that black people
tell about white people
there is no synonymous joke going the
other direction it doesn't exist
what's more i think we can all we all
know that
if chris rock had made a joke about a
white woman
i mean he's told many jokes about white
women many times for many years but if
on that particular night he had happened
to joke about a white woman and her
white husband strode onto the stage and
slapped him across the face
we could be quite sure that there would
be nobody defending him
the guy doing the slapping that is and
he would have been arrested and charged
with a hate crime before he could even
get back to his seat
that's the real lesson we could take
from this
and there are two others
uh related less to the incident itself
and more to the reaction on the left to
the incident first
we see how the racial victim narrative
is superimposed onto everything
regardless of the facts on the ground
it doesn't matter this was black on
black crime doesn't matter that the men
involved had the same race same
socioeconomic status same gender same
age same sexual orientation
you would think if you didn't know any
better
that one rich black man slapping another
rich black man at the oscars would be an
event impervious to racial tribalization
if there's any story that cannot be
intersectionalized it would be this you
might think
but you'd be wrong
the race hustlers as we've learned time
and time again they need only for a
black person to be involved that's all
the clay they need to mold the image
they want to mold from it and even if
there was no black person involved even
if this was white on white violence
you know leonardo dicaprio slapping tom
cruise or something like that which
would have been great by the way still
they could make black people the victim
second most importantly we see that the
left
is serious when they say that words are
violence now of course that statement is
heavily qualified words
insulting or joking about
certain groups of people are violence
i mean you can of course say whatever
the hell you want about straight white
people chris rock could have done a
15-minute routine where he fantasized
openly about rounding up all the white
people in the room and burning them
alive and it would have been considered
comedic brilliance
he could have actually rounded them all
up and really burned them alive and it's
arguable whether he'd be in jail right
now
that much is established
but words attacking or supposedly
attacking or simply just criticizing or
lightly mocking
members of a protected class are indeed
violence in the minds of a leftist
why well
this is where the story ties in with
everything else we're witnessing in our
culture it intersects with gender
ideology
which is a topic that i explored by the
way in my best-selling women's studies
book what is a woman available now for
pre-order what is woman.com
for an individual in a protected class
their their self perceptions their
feelings especially their feelings about
themselves are just as important as
their physical well-being
that's the way it's seen in our culture
in fact even more important
remember in the modern world we have
assumed the power to make ourselves we
are forever engaged in the never-ending
process of self-creation
the most important version of yourself
is not your physical self your actual
self but the self you have constructed
in your imagination
physical violence cannot necessarily
touch your imagined self
which is your most important self again
but words can ideas can
ideas can even kill a person's imagined
self their self perception
and so in that sense words are violence
the worst kind of violence
this obviously applies most to a
person's so-called gender identity but
it applies to everything else that they
think and feel about themselves
jaina pinkett smith had spoken publicly
before the night of the oscars even
recently um about how she loves her bald
head she's proud of it she thinks it's
beautiful
now that's obviously not true she
doesn't really think that or else she
wouldn't be so sensitive to jokes about
it i mean if you're really proud of
something and you think it's great and
beautiful and you have no problem with
it and somebody tells a joke about it
it's it's it's not gonna make any den at
all on you it's just gonna bounce right
off you because you you're you're
confident
so she's not really confident about it
as she pretends but she wants to think
that way about herself
that's the self-perception she is trying
to
conjure up and create and maintain
a joke obstructs that process
and so it's violence
it's violence against the version of
herself
she is trying to perceive
that's what they mean when they say
words or violence
it's all completely insane of course
but it's the world we're living in
nonetheless
and it's good to try to understand it to
the extent that we can
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated